mike is in pensacola florida to start
off this hour
hey mike how can we help hey dave and
christy thanks for taking my call how
are we all doing
better than we deserve what's up well
uh my wife and i are debt free minus our
house
we have an emergency fund we're about to
start investing in a 401k
and don't worry we do not own beanie
babies
[Laughter]
we're good so i'm calling
about our home we're looking to relocate
to a
better school district in a safer
neighborhood and
you know real estate of course and this
market's crazy i know nothing about it
so we're looking to see if we should
sell now and buy
later being that we have the available
funds for a down payment
and we have the a
place to live in the interim for free my
father-in-law's house he's been very
generous
um as far as future predictions will the
market go down later should we sell our
house go live with him and then buy
later what are your thoughts on that
i do not think this is a bubble
okay and that would be the only way it
would go down
i think the i think the craziness will
slow
and the rate of increase in prices will
slow
but i don't think this is a false bubble
that's going to course correct in the
house prices in pensacola florida are
going to go down dramatically
anytime in the next decade
what that means is if you buy and step
out of the most flooding the market but
yeah what that means is as you step out
of the market
every day you wait to get back in the
prices are going up for the rest of your
life
so it's definitely not a good idea to
sell now and buy later it's a good idea
to sell now and buy
sounds now it nothing nothing nothing
wrong with that because it's an even
swap you're going to get the benefit of
the heated market on the sale
and you're going to uh have the problem
of the ben of the heated market on the
buy
so i'm curious about this dave because
we we got some calls like this last week
and i was talking to you about this even
off air
but are you thinking there's going to be
any kind of dip because right now like
nashville specifically with
these cash buyers coming from california
so it's so much
people are paying so much over appraisal
and list price you're not seeing that go
down you're thinking it's just going to
level out and then
keep going i mean i'm curious about this
because we we hear about this all the
time the only thing that dropped in 2008
2008 the first time
in my 35 years of having a real estate
license
that prices across the nation went down
it's the only time i've ever seen it was
in 2008.
now i've seen particular markets bubble
up and pop
and those have to do with particular
things in those markets
but you know florida does not have any
of those issues i don't um you know
for instance i'll give an example i
don't know what's going to happen in
california
yeah because there's a mass exodus yeah
people are leaving
there's there's a stream of u-hauls
going of interstate
going down the interstate leaving the
state uh as fast as they can possibly
flee
and so uh and they're going to texas
tennessee florida
uh and buying houses and so what's that
going to do to that real estate market
eventually if enough of that continues
mathematics tells us that that will hurt
prices in california
it hasn't yet california is quite hot
you put a house on the market you'll
sell in three days right now in la and
so it's not like all these people
leaving have affected there's
that gummy people there that you know
that you you take a while to empty the
state you know
and so but they are they are pouring out
of there for sure
and uh those of us that are in the
markets that they are coming to
know it yeah i mean we go out here at
the commercial breaks right here
and uh you know we i haven't been
out of this room to go out and meet
people at a commercial break i don't
think a single time
in uh five months that i didn't meet
somebody from california that's here
looking at houses
i mean every dadgum and so that's an
example of a particular market
that has unique problems in that case
created by the governor
uh but uh and because covet is not worse
in california than it is in tennessee
and texas
and so it's just absolute bs but the uh
uh but the bottom line is you know and
we've seen this before in other markets
where
um you know something unique happens a
uh a uh
manufacturing plant shuts down and it
was a that
labor base was a big part of that market
then you can see that market correct
but overall just because it's going up
does not mean it's going to come down
matter of fact you have a hard time
proving that you know i
i can think back again i got my real
estate license in 1978
i have seen very few times that you've
seen
prices go down from where they were
four months before and stay down for
more than 20 seconds
yeah i just wasn't sure if it was such a
unique situation because of the
amount of overpaying right well they're
overpaying
but are they if enough of them are going
to set that new if enough of them are
doing it
that is now the price that's the new bar
yeah and so the definition
when i went through appraisal class and
when i was getting my degree in real
estate
the definition of value of market value
is what a willing buyer is able is
willing to give a willing seller where
neither party is in duress
so in other words if you're buying a
foreclosure that's someone in duress you
wouldn't count that in an appraisal
but if two perfectly healthy situations
and they're paying a whole lot even more
than asking price
then you know where we're getting
multiple offers on a property and that
kind of stuff you know put it on the
market you got 30 offers in the weekend
those kinds of stories are happening all
over then that is the new value so when
people say
i'm not going to overpay for a house
they're not overpaying that's the new
well i mean you know you're you're
overpaying what it's what it's what it
would have brought two months ago right
right right and you're overpaying what
it would have brought monday yeah
but by tuesday yeah i don't know yeah
because
these prices are being driven up by this
supply because what has happened is with
the lumber shortage
right it's driven the price of lumber up
cost new housing is going up new housing
is also
more harder to get out of the ground and
so we have
we have an inventory problem and so
anytime there's a shortage of
anything and there's more people chasing
that thing than there is
thing you that's a supply demand curve
from the seventh grade
economics class it drives price up yeah
that even works with beanie babies
[Laughter]
when too few when too few people i mean
when a big bunch of dollars are chasing
too few things
yeah then those things go up anything
that has scarcity
in other words you'd always see the
price go up and so what will happen is
is this market will calm down as the
inventory gets rebuilt
as the lumber factories get to build and
get to making lumber again at the same
pace or an increased pace to offset this
and the prices come back are they at
least the lumber prices will come back
down
that i do think but that's not going to
necessarily affect real estate values
overall so anyway yes i i don't have any
problem with you buying right now
or selling right now but i would do both
of whatever you're gonna do
get out of the market whatever you're
gonna do i mean it's uh
i'm enjoying watching the real estate
that i own go way up in value
it's just awesome yeah kinda kinda like
it
so you know and that's that's the stuff
so my goodness yeah that's what i would
do i think it's time for you to move sir
and i would and i would buy when you
move
this is the ramsey show